how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and we
just got
episode three of the wanda vision series
on disney plus
and what an episode it was and although
we seem to have gotten some
game-changing easter eggs in this
episode we are still left with some
questions that we don't have the answers
to
but i believe in this episode thanks to
some very well spotted easter eggs we
have discovered what each
villain's role will be and what exactly
they want from wanda
now most of the major events take place
within the last
7 minutes of this episode not including
the credits
there are some important parts to talk
about that happen within the first 20
minutes of the episode which we will go
over but most of the reveals come
in the final minutes but the episode
starts off just
like the brady bunch and although some
people might not look too much into this
there seems to be a very obvious trend
of
hexagons now this is done very very
intentionally by marvel studios because
this is not how the original brady bunch
intro looks in the brady bunch intro
they actually use
squares not hexagons so marvel
specifically put these hexagons there
now what's extremely interesting about
hexagons is that a hexagon is actually
the logo for
aim aim stands for advanced idea
mechanics and
aim is mostly associated with the
villain modok
but we do know that one division has
been calling back to
hydra there's even an easter egg and a
commercial in this
episode that shows hydra so it could be
that aim is simply a branch of hydra or
simply the new hydra they may not be
going by the name hydra they may be
going by aim now
either way it definitely looks like aim
and hydra are both a part of whatever
is happening in one division now the
last time we left wanda and vision
wanda was magically and suddenly
pregnant and when we start off this
episode
wanda and vision have the doctor over
and if you notice wanda seems to be
perfectly fine and actually very
happy with being suddenly pregnant while
vision is actually kind of freaking out
about it
and this is actually very
counter-intuitive to how vision
typically is
normally he's calm cool collected and
calculating after all he is kind of a
robot but here he seems to be very human
which is not
like vision but the doctor says that
wanda is four months along
he leaves and vision asks the doctor to
keep wanda's pregnancy
a secret then we get a very peculiar
scene with vision
and his neighbor herb herb is trimming
his hedges but he's actually cut through
the hedges and is now
cutting through the wall vision catches
this and calls him out on it in a very
friendly way
he says hey herb i think you might have
taken the hedge trimming a little too
far there old chum
and then herb looks at him eyes wide
open
and says so i have thanks buddy and
continues to cut through the wall but
his eyes
never leave vision now we know wanda is
in a different reality but this whole
entire time we have been wondering
what exactly the other people's roles
are in this reality
and it seems to be getting more certain
that these people are under
some sort of a trance this is seemingly
demonstrated in this scene with herb he
doesn't seemingly have much control over
what is going on and it's a very odd
scene
and it even bugs vision vision can tell
that something's not normal but
vision isn't exactly normal either
vision goes back inside and wanda is
even bigger we then go to a scene where
wanda and vision
mostly wanda with her powers are setting
up the baby's room putting together the
crib
and all the other items wanda pulls out
a babymobile the thing that hangs over
the baby's crib that has a bunch of
butterflies on it then all of a sudden
the baby
kicks and right after the baby kicks the
butterflies all come to life and start
flying around the room
in which wanda says oh did i do that i
didn't mean to
now if you've watched the episode
already you know that wanda actually has
twins wanda and vision only thought they
were going to have one kid in which they
argued over the name
billy or tommy luckily they had twins so
they named their twins billy and tommy
and
if you are unfamiliar with who wanda and
visions kids are in the comics they are
actually
wiccan and speed and wiccan has the
powers of his mother the scarlet witch
and speed has the abilities of his
uncle quicksilver he's super fast so
what actually happened here was wanda's
child
wiccan who has the same abilities that
she had made the butterflies come to
life
not her which is why she asks oh did i
do that because she actually didn't but
at this point little does she know
that one of her kids has the exact same
powers that she does this continues on
to when wanda
actually goes into labor as she starts
to have contractions the lights flicker
and the power goes out not only in her
house but in the whole neighborhood
also it begins to rain when her water
breaks now this is most likely a
combination of her powers kind of going
out of control because she's going into
labor and her son wiccan's powers but if
it is her doing this she clearly does
not have control over her powers
vision also starts to freak out flying
into the air and wanda has to calm him
down with her breathing technique
again this is not vision this vision has
emotions he freaks out he's almost
hysterical in some parts whereas the
normal vision that we know
would know exactly what is going on and
be very calm this is more evidence that
this vision that we see here may not
actually be alive and if he is he is
definitely not the same
vision that wanda knew but whoever this
vision is realizes that something is
wrong
wanda says that she feels like the
people of west view are always on the
verge of discovering her secret
and vision says yes i know what you mean
vision seems to have caught on that the
reality isn't exactly
real he says that it's more than people
discovering their secret
then the background music gets very very
eerie and vision says i think there's
something wrong here
but right after he says that he is reset
we saw this happen before in episode 2
at the very end
the beekeeper came into the reality
wanda said no
and reset it so wanda clearly has
control over this reality
or does she we'll talk about that in
just a bit now here's where we get a
really
interesting commercial that is for hydra
soap now again
aim could simply be hydra or a
department of hydra either way it's
clear that hydra is somewhat involved in
what is happening but the words to this
commercial actually describe what is
happening in wanda's reality
the narration of the hydra commercial
says escape to a world all your own
where your problems float away when you
want to get away but don't want to go
anywhere
hydra soak find the goddess within this
is
essentially describing wanda in this
reality she's escaped to a world of her
own a reality where she can control
what happens vision is alive and she's
married to him and they're pregnant
about to have children
she's escaped from all of her problems
after avengers end game her brother
being dead
vision being dead her problems have
floated away and she's gone but she's
still
on earth she's simply in a bubble
reality so that's when it says
when you want to get away but don't want
to go anywhere she hasn't actually gone
anywhere she has simply created a
different reality
around her now wanda starts to go more
into labor and vision runs off to get
the doctor
wanda hears a noise coming from the
nursery but then monica
taps on the door now in this reality her
name is geraldine but we know that her
real name is monica rambo in the real
world
she comes over to borrow a bucket and
wanda tries to hide that she's pregnant
but eventually she starts to go into
labor and can't hide it anymore
she starts to help wanda give birth and
as one is giving birth
things kind of go into madness if you
will photo starts spinning on the wall
the chandelier falls and the fire
ignites in flames which i think is a
reference to mafesto
and his hell realm now during the labor
process
wanda can't really control her powers
and what's really interesting about her
not being able to control her powers and
the reality is the stork scene that we
got right before she gave birth
a stork magically showed up which isn't
that shocking a lot of things are
happening since wanda can't control her
powers and
her child wiccan is most likely causing
things to happen as well
but the stork is not a product of wanda
or her son
the key point is that wanda actually
tries to get rid of the stork
but can't she tries several times but
all we see
is red smoke this is very big because
this means that
wanda can't actually fully control this
reality
somebody else can more on this in just a
bit when i reveal the villain's
master plan for everything that is
happening wanda eventually gives birth
to her son
vision returns with the doctor but
geraldine takes the doctor in the
kitchen
so wanda and vision could have some time
alone wanda says don't you want to meet
your son as yourself and vision turns
into the synthezoid then
wanda screams because she's having
another baby and vision screams and
freaks out as well yelling
what again not normal vision now it's
very interesting that they didn't know
that wanda was having twins this is
actually from a comic storyline where
wanda is having her kids and doctor
strange didn't know that wanda was
having twins either
now this is where things start to get
very very intense
vision walks the doctor out and the
doctor says that he most likely won't go
on his trip anymore and he says small
towns are so hard to escape
and he puts a very weird emphasis on
this like it's very
important vision seems like he's kind of
starting to realize things aren't right
again
but as he's having this epiphany he
hears his neighbors talking
and it's hard to make out but if you put
on the closed captions we can hear what
they say
agnes whispers what is she doing in
there herb says
i don't know and then vision says hi and
they say hi back they continue to
whisper to each other and agnes says
did you see her go inside and herb says
she went right in
agnes says and her tummy was did
geraldine
then vision comes over and the last
thing we hear agnes say is
that's fine now this is quite possibly
the most important scene that we've had
so far in one division
vision asks if they lost power and agnes
says yes but ralph looks better in the
dark
this is another mention of her husband
ralph that we've never
seen now agnes and herb start to ask
vision
if geraldine is inside with wanda vision
is very concerned and agnes and herb
start to talk about
how strange geraldine is they say she's
new to town
no family no husband vision says well
that's all right
but then agnes and herb just look at him
and say
no home vision says what do you mean she
has no home
then we get what seems to be a huge
reveal of what is actually happening
here in this reality
herb says she came here because she came
here because we're all and then agnes
stops him from saying it
now what he was most likely going to say
here
is that we're all trapped here it's
clear that the people inside have some
sort of a trance over them
but some of them seem to be aware that
they are in this other reality and that
they can't escape
this also lines up with what the doctor
said small towns
so hard to escape so clearly some people
are aware
that they can't leave and they're also
aware that monica
is not one of the people involved in
whatever is going on
now while this is happening monica is
with wanda and wanda says
i'm a twin i had a brother beetro and
she starts to sing to the kids in
sokovian
but geraldine has a sudden awakening and
she says
pedro was killed by ultron so the trance
that was over her while her being in
this reality is slowly starting to fade
as she realizes more and more
unfortunately this upsets wanda and
wanda starts to kind of freak out
she asks what she said and it appears
that geraldine realizes
that she shouldn't have said what she
said but is now very aware of where she
is
and who wanda is she tries to avoid
talking about what she just discussed
but wanda says what did you say about
pietro
and wanda realizes that her new reality
is starting to be threatened
she then tells her to leave but
geraldine tells her not to be like that
then she sees the emblem on geraldine's
necklace geraldine acts like she doesn't
know what it is because she doesn't want
to tell wanda because that is the sword
emblem now in the comics sword stands
for sentient world observation and
response department but in the mcu they
have apparently changed it to sentient
weapon observation and response
department and sword is basically a
different department
of shield however in the mcu shield may
have simply changed their name to sword
but is still basically the same
department
now as geraldine stumbles for words
wanda starts to slowly walk
towards her and as we can see on wanda's
face she is not very happy and she feels
very
threatened the next thing you know
vision walks in and
geraldine is gone the music gets very
creepy and has a very big
horror tone to it wanda is watching her
new babies
vision asks where's geraldine and in a
very
creepy scene she says oh she left honey
she had to rush home
wanda smiles in a very creepy way and
then
the frame of the episode expands and
were taken
outside of what seems to be some type of
bubble or energy force field and out
comes geraldine whose real name of
course
is monica rambo once she gets out sword
immediately
comes to her and surrounds her and we
can see in the background that there is
clearly some type of energy field
around the town of westview that they
are trapped in
now what exactly is happening here well
here is the biggest easter egg that we
possibly got in one division
when vision is talking to agnes and herb
we can see that agnes is wearing a
necklace now this necklace
is actually the same brooch that she was
wearing in previous episodes and here we
get a
very good look at it what seems to be on
it is
three different people one clearly looks
to be the grim
reaper because we can see a scythe on it
plus in the last episode of one division
we got
an easter egg for the grim reaper so we
know that he's going to be involved
somehow
the other two look to maybe be children
so here's what i think is happening the
demon mephisto who is in charge of the
hell realm
basically the devil is controlling this
reality and he is somehow possessing
wanda
that is why in the last episode episode
2 the last words that we heard
were wanda who is doing this to you so
we know sword is observing
her but they're not controlling her
because somebody else is and they don't
know who it is
this same person has trapped everybody
else in this reality bubble
so mephisto controls this reality and
working for him
is agnes aka agatha harkness the witch
and the grim reaper this is all a plan
to get wanda's kids who are actually
mephisto's kids and mephisto wants them
back now that they're born
and the way to get them back into the
hell realm is to kill them which is
where the grim reaper
comes in so the brooch and necklace that
agatha wears
is actually the grim reaper and two
children wanda envisions children
wiccan and speed i also believe that the
crane was either mephisto
or agatha if you think about it vision
can't exactly give wanda kids
and in the comics what happens is the
children are actually shards of the soul
of mephisto
they are his kids which is most likely
what is happening here
and if you think of the significance of
the stork the stork
brings children just like mephisto most
likely brought these children into wanda
now as the stork he is spying on wanda
giving birth this would also explain
why wanda could not get rid of the stork
it's actually mephisto and it's his
reality so she cannot control that
that would also explain the red smoke
that went off whenever wanda would try
to get rid of the stork as well
so what i think is most likely happening
here is that mephisto
wanted children for whatever reason and
he picked wanda to have them because
she's an extremely powerful witch he
trapped her inside of this reality and
put children inside of her agatha
harkness is working for mephisto and is
in charge of containing the reality
and the grim reaper is working for him
and will return the children to mephisto
by killing them this will ultimately
lead to wanda
exploding she lost her brother she lost
vision
then she loses her children this will
lead up to the events in doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness where
wanda might be
a villain there's certainly a lot going
on in one division and it's certainly
very hard to pinpoint what exactly is
happening but this is my theory so let
me know what you think about it in the
comments down below
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any theories and breakdowns don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
you